hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round six of this
year's Tata Ste Chess Masters it is
Notre abdat versus Anish giri two Rivals
from last year starta steel Chess
Masters event uh Notre Beck finished
with eight points last year and Anish
with eight and a half points Notre Beck
had shared second with Magnus Carlson
and Anish won the tournament in so so
first place uh so it was an incredible
incredible victory for Anish and of
course he would very much like to win
this year as well make it two years in a
row but nobe of course uh as he does
have the white pieces against the Nish
will try his best for that not to happen
so let's check it out uh with the white
pieces Notre opens with Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to E5 by Anish he even made a
course on this reply we have Knight to
F3 Knight to F6 going for the Petro
defense and now Knight captures on E5
the main line or the classical variation
of the Petro uh D6 chasing away the
Knight Knight F3 and now Knight captures
on e4 and there are many possible
continuations here here D4 is the main
move Knight to C3 second most popular
Queen to E2 third most popular D3 fourth
most popular notbe goes for Pawn to C4
this is the fifth most popular
continuation against this line of the
Petro and he says all right Anish let's
see let's see what you got here so okay
Bishop D7 of course Anish knows how to
play this line uh but even if you don't
you just want to Castle your king to
safety as quickly as possible especially
against the Tactical Beast like Norbeck
Knight to C3 Knight captures D captures
and now an each just castles we have
Bishop to
D3 Knight to D7 and Bishop to E3 Norbeck
developing his Bishops in the style of
Paul morphe and there is one game where
Knight to E5 was played but an he just
goes for the solid Knight F6 and it is
now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so okay Pawn to H3
uh Notre well within his preparation all
of his moves have been made without
losing any time he still has a an hour
and 33 minutes on the clock which is
more than you start with you start with
hour and a half and Anish did drop down
to an hour and 18 minutes with his next
Pawn to B6 move so Anish has to figure
out how to play against this um as you
don't just play a move like Pawn to H3
you know Blitz it out against a player
like Anish if you don't have it well
prepared so okay Queen to C2 putting
some pressure on that H7 pawn and Bishop
to B7 we have Queen side castles and now
Pawn to H6 and um okay Pawn to H6 is
useful the Knight can now move you don't
have to worry about the H7 pawn and here
is the first real think of the uh game
for Notre backck uh he spends 20 minutes
on this move and he plays Rook H to E1
and it's very interesting especially I
found it interesting that when you have
castles of opposite sides you have White
Castle Queen side black Castle King side
your instinct is to you know push those
pawns on the king side Checkmate the the
black king as soon as possible you have
the Bishops here okay you probably have
to move the Rook from H1 but maybe put
it to G1 push G4 G5 I mean it does look
great and even the engine says Rook to
G1 uh is is okay for white but nor
played Rook H to E1 which just shows
what uh what a classy player he is uh
and okay uh here we have Rook to E8 by
Anish and now Bishop to D4 the Bishops
are now fully operational uh controlling
these two main diagonals towards the
black king and pawn to C5 Anish says all
right your Bishop can't simply remain
there and now Bishop captures an F6 not
what you would expect in such an open
game for Notre backck to give up his
Bishop pair like this uh but after an
each Bishop captures on F6 you can see
that this setup B2 C3 uh does limit the
the power of the bishop on F6 so okay
and here I I think comes the move that I
like most in the entire game and that is
Bishop to H7 with check uh on you know
on first glance it doesn't really do
anything you just give a check and the
black king can actually go to f8 and h8
doesn't really matter uh but okay on f8
it could be a bit more vulnerable
especially if the bishop moves and you
allow the queen to H7 so so it makes
sense to play King to h8 uh but other
than that it doesn't really uh uh seem
to have any any great purpose but uh as
the game progresses you will see uh that
it definitely does uh Bishop back to E4
now attacking the undefended bishop on
B7 and okay on each trades here we have
Bishop captures Rook captures and queen
to D7 connecting Rook so now if not back
trades you can bring the other Rook into
the game uh but not just plays Knight to
D2 uh prepares the uh uh Advance the F
Pawn and also the Knight is now
defending the C4 Pawn if at any point uh
you play something like Pawn to B5 so on
each first place Pawn to A6 now comes
King to B1 just getting the king to a
safer Square Bishop to G5 and now Knight
back to F3 attacking the bishop Bishop
back to F6 by an each and now notbe
plays Queen to D3 and here comes Pawn to
B5 uh the problem with something like
Rook captures on e4 and queen captures
on e4 uh is that um okay Rook to d8 can
be played and now if Queen to D5 it
doesn't look like much for black because
this is just a permanent weakness but
still after a move like Queen to A4
doesn't seem like white has all that
much to do here it's um you know B5 is
coming could be even nice for black uh
but okay in the game Ponto B5 was played
right away by Anish and now comes Knight
back to D2 but not right away uh first
after B5 Notre backck trades Rooks Rook
captures on E8 we have Queen captures on
E8 uh and now Knight to D2 you can't
really capture on D6 if you capture on
D6 Rook d8 wins the game for Anish so I
hope none of you were looking at that
pawn so Queen captures an8 Knight to D2
and now okay you could open up the B
file and it does seem like something you
want to do uh you know you have the
bishop uh you have the Rook here so
maybe but uh how do you deal with this
D6 weakness and uh this doesn't really
do anything uh for the moment so okay
after Knight to D2 Queen to E6 was
played putting more pressure on that C4
Pawn now just Knight to E4 attacking the
bishop on each brings it back and now
Queen to D5 offering a queen trade and
you can't really afford this queen trade
if you trade Queens here for example
captures captures your Pawn is still
hanging and if look to d8 uh then you
just captur C captures on B5 a captures
and now Pawn to B4 and that's it uh the
pawn cannot capture otherwise Rook
captures on B5 but other than that what
what do you play see captures is coming
and you're going to you're going to win
a pawn regardless of what black plays so
Queen to D5 uh Rook to d8 adding a
Defender to the D6 pawn and now just C
captures on B5 a captures and pawn to F4
it's a really another really classy move
by Notre backck as stops G5 F5 cannot be
played as the queen is saying so Anish
is really really Limited in his options
and what he can play something like Pawn
to G6 although it's very hard to say
what this move does other than prevent
F5 uh he goes King back to G8 he knows
that if he wants to survive this and
trade down into some sort of end game
the king really should come to the queen
side and now that little check that
notbe gave on H7 forcing anish's King to
h8 uh means that Anish is a Tempo down
in uh moving the king over to the queen
side so now Pawn F5 attacking the queen
and you have to go back Queen to C8 and
then you know you just suffer in in a
worse position but Anish decided to
trade Queens here and here comes a rook
captures D5 King to f8 and now Pawn to
B4 uh again capturing doesn't really do
anything B5 will fall so King to E8 and
now King to B2 nck also improves the
position of his King and now uh Rook to
D7 trying to get his King into the game
uh this way uh but uh it doesn't work
here there is a very strong reply Pawn
to G4 uh and now after King to d8 feel
free to pause the video and figure out
what notbe played here uh win the
position for white while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this rather explosive idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Pawn to C4 this is the move and
now uh you you realize that there is no
way of holding the pawn uh the problem
is if you play C captur and B4 uh then C
captur and B5 and now after King to C7
just King to B3 and after let's say King
B6 you will capture here A4 A5 check uh
that's it there's no no way out of this
so B captures and C4 was played now B
captures and C5 uh D captures and C5
because if you go King to C7 to try and
defend again you just trade everything
captures and after Bishop captures you
play Rook captures Rook captures Knight
captures captures King goes here King
goes here and okay your Pawn is defended
it's equal material but Pawn A4 A5 black
king will have to go after the the pawn
you will capture this Pawn pick up all
of these pawns and uh it's a it's a very
easy Elementary end game to win so D
captures on C5 was played uh but it
doesn't help Rook captures on D7 King
captures and King to C3 now this is a
crucial move to play uh King to C6 and
now King captures on C4 so similar to
the end game that we discussed only with
the inclusion of the bishop and Knight
on the board however that doesn't change
anything um in anisha's favor so King to
B6 now comes Pawn to A4 we have King
back to C6 waiting to see what notbe
will do uh or okay you could go King to
A5 as we've discussed but Knight
captures and C5 defends the pawn and if
you trade then it's what we've discussed
then the the white king just picks up
all the pawns uh and wins the game
easily so after Pawn to A4 King to C6
was played and now Knight to F2 uh this
is move 40 so time control has been
reached we have Bishop to d8 and the
Knight to E4 now putting pressure on the
pawn so again again Anish defends it but
now Pawn to A5 uh we have Bishop back to
d8 now comes Pawn to A6 and it does does
look like you're weakening the pawn
because the black king can attack it but
like we said Knight captures on C5 uh
just defends the pawn and if you attack
it doesn't really do anything for
example Bishop to D7 uh pretty much any
move wins here you can even play King to
D5 and if Bishop captures you just play
A7 King captures King captures and again
your king is much closer you will pick
up the pawns and your pawns uh will
advance to become Queens so after A6
Bishop to E7 was played and now uh there
is but one way that you can win this
game so feel free to pause the video and
uh you know win it while I give you a
couple of
seconds uh so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being
true masters of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
to show it is Knight to C3 this is the
way to do it because as you can see
there's no other way to improve your
position uh if you just um move the
Knight to to a weird Square uh then the
king can just go after the pawn uh so
it's important to uh move it somewhere
where where the king cannot go after the
pawn and that is Knight to C3 there's
also the engine move Pawn to F6 because
the the the capture of the pawn doesn't
change the position you just play Knight
C3 after that so it's the same solution
uh but okay Knight to C three and now uh
the problem is if you go King to B6 now
Knight D5 check picks up the bishop so
the bishop is very poorly placed there
uh Bishop to G5 was played now comes
Knight to B5 and after Bishop to E3
adding a Defender here uh Pawn to H4 by
Notre backck we have King to B6 now
comes Pawn to A7 defending the Pawn King
to B7 guarding the queening square and
now comes Pawn to H5 and here uh
although the position is completely
winning for notbe Anish even stood up he
took down his jacket and then he sat
down again trying to you know think
deeply about the position about what he
could do and there was even quite the
crowd watching the the local hero of of
vians you can see a lot of people
watching their game there you have
Anisha nrec um you know same position uh
same stance um people are are are
waiting to see if their hero will
survive this uh but it is very unlikely
King to A8 was played you could also
play Pawn to F6 but with Pawn to six you
free up D E6 Square for the white king
and then it's a fairly fairly easy win
uh so King to A8 was played onious plan
is now all right I move the king back
and forth see see see how how you deal
with it King to D5 King to B7 and now
King to D6 and now the problem is again
if you go King to A8 uh King to E7 and
now let's say Pawn to C4 King captures
on F7 Bishop captures on A7 hoping for
Knight capture so you can advance the
pawn uh but the king will just ignore
you and okay now now uh DF Pawn wins and
the C3 square is still guarded by the
Knight so instead Pawn to C4 uh and now
we have King to D5 going after the pawn
uh you don't have to turn this into a
race or anything you can just eliminate
the pawn and then win the game this way
so Bishop captures on A7 Knight captures
on A7 and now Pawn to C3 uh but it
doesn't matter Knight to C6 and it seems
like there's no way for the Knight to
actually catch the pass Pawn but after
C2 there's the there there's this check
Knight to A5 check King to C7 and now
Knight to B3 guarding the queening
square we have King to D7 now comes Pawn
to uh Pawn to G5 and here just King to
E7 the problem is uh if you capture the
pawn on G5 uh it's uh sort of the oldest
endgame book um uh endgame trick in the
book for example captures F6 threatening
captures and promotion and after black
captures all of your pawns the last
remaining Pawn will emerge Victorious so
after King to E7 G captures on H6 was
played G captures and now King to
E5 uh Pawn to F6 with check King to E5
with have King to D7 and now Knight to
C1 and he was in this position un move
60 that norbe AB well that Anish gir
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the position
would be winning for for NRE even
without the the Knight and Pawn on the
board if it was anish's move because you
are in s Swang and the point is that
let's say go King D7 King to C6 there's
no King E6 to you know uh to maintain
opposition and then you have to choose
you either go King to d8 then white G
gains the opposition and after King to
E8 you get King E6 opposition and then
you you start eliminating all of the
pawns or the other way around after King
C6 and King to d8 uh or may King to F7
right away uh you will again grab a
position King D7 after King f8 moves now
you go to E6 and after King to G7
defending again you gain opposition you
cannot go here King goes up upwards and
now you capture the pawns and uh promote
the this DF Pawn for example yeah fairly
fairly simple stuff and of course after
Knight to C1 Anish was forced to resign
the game so yeah very nicely done by
notbe last year uh he uh he was
undefeated for the entire tournament and
then he lost the final game to to Jordan
pan forest and that was what enabled
Anish to to clinch first Place uh but um
let me just check if the other games
have finished no they're still being
played and some some very very
interesting uh development wow uh one of
the games that everyone was sure was
going to be a draw seems that it will
not be a draw uh but I'm not going to
spoil anything you know probably we'll
cover it so uh stay tuned uh until that
time comes uh so once again hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Brian
pin Johan clens Len Herbert Yong and
Christopher and Ruth ber for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and yeah
brilliant brilliant stuff by Notre back
here uh see you soon